welcome to Hannity tonight major
progress in our fight against Coppa 19
facts without fear if the current
pattern holds corona virus could be
leveling off as we speak that means it
will be followed by a dramatic decline
again if the models hold one frequently
cited model which predicted a death toll
remember without any travel ban
quarantine any mitigation would have
been 2.2 million as high as 2.2 million
Americans dying then we had the big
signs what ten days ago 240,000 that was
revised down to eighty one thousand two
days ago and it has been revised
downward again to sixty thousand one
question we do all need to ask tonight
is how these numbers have been so far
off the mark and how do we safely open
up this country as soon as possible we
have a lot of ideas and will also
balance the medical side of this with
dr. oz versus the economic side and
getting our lives back to normal
meanwhile the number of predicted
hospitalizations that fell from one
hundred and forty thousand and ninety
thousand that same model is now
reporting that the peak is just three
days away meanwhile in the epicenter
where we are in New York State well new
hospitalizations are roughly half of
what they were a week ago and four days
more patients have been released that
have been admitted now keep in mind the
model predicted that the state would
need 70,000 hospital beds over 12,000
ICU beds at this point instead well New
York who's only needed 16,000 500 beds
and just over four thousand ICU beds and
about a third of the predicted need in
the state of New Jersey only three of
the state's 72 hospitals are at capacity
no state has experienced a surge
anywhere near what was told and expected
the Trump administration meanwhile has
shipped out over 11 million n95 masks
over 8,000 ventilators 10,000 additional
ventilators are ready to be shipped out
as needed and 2200 more will be
available Monday now while we continue
to fight cope with 19 this country must
also harness its ingenuity its
brilliance the free market system and
figure a way to get a mare
Americans safely back to work as soon as
possible where they want to be
you can't allow America's businesses to
wither and on the vine and die there are
parts of this country with very low
incidence of kovat 19 that likely yeah
we can open those areas probably now but
with 22 days away from May first
geographical openings will be a
no-brainer but even in these areas there
will be some changes moving forward
especially to avoid a rebound and here's
the key we have to open up the economy
in a way that prevents future outbreaks
it immediately contains them but also
protects your civil liberties your
constitutional rights one reality we
must all understand and accept rebounds
of the virus will happen not if they
happen it will happen one thing that
can't happen is we cannot shut down the
country like this again a comprehensive
plan that balances both aspects of this
needs to be implemented we'll be
thinking of new ways new paradigms just
as we have throughout this entire
pandemic
for example employers could utilize
contact less digital thermometers
remember I went to the Navy hospital
ship the comfort they took my
temperature didn't touch me they can
check their employees temperatures as
they're entering buildings especially in
big cities face mask elbow bumps instead
of handshakes telecommuting could now
become a temporary new normal and get up
business up and running social
distancing on some level as well one
huge challenge is going to be
restaurants and bars do we take
temperatures when people enter a place
to eat do you limit the number of people
that any one restaurant can have that's
going to be hard testing though I
believe will likely be this key solution
to all of this if we can have widespread
distribution of these newly approved not
only the antibody tests but the
five-minute Cova 19 test results do you
have it or not have it that could play a
huge part in opening up the country all
over the place more quickly more safely
then contract contact tracing will also
come into play so how quickly can these
testing methods be available for example
can
abbit mass-produced their testing and
doing 50,000 a day now or who have the
capability we're told can they build out
other manufacturing centers for the
testing equipment and get them to big
cities like New York because time is of
the essence now another factor that
comes into play is patient privacy yeah
that matters constitutional rights civil
liberties we cannot violate this in any
way period it's not an option in the
United States of America
there will be no database people must be
ensured complete privacy and complete
anonymity in all of this now also you
would think that the cooperation of
people will factor in as well now if
this shutdown goes on for months on end
America will not be the America we grew
up in very specific challenges for very
specific businesses massive challenges
for big cities like New York City small
medium and large businesses will go
belly-up if we're not careful no amount
of government aid is going to solve that
problem lifelong dreams will be
shattered lives will be ruined
the hardship could and under those
circumstances go on for years the toll
the misery would be like unlike anything
we've ever seen in modern history but
for some reason you got many doomsday
Democrats media mob people and he
completely and totally irresponsible
from whatever background they want the
shutdown seemingly to continue
indefinitely regardless of facts that
are on the ground for example yesterday
one of Joe Biden's top advisors Zeke
Emanuel was called for the shutdown to
constitute good to continue rather for
at least another 18 months is he out of
his mind
take a look realistically kovat 19 will
be here for the next 18 months or more
we will not be able to return to
normalcy until we find a vaccine or
effective medications I know that's
dreadful news to hear if we prematurely
end that physical distancing and the
other measures keeping it at bay deaths
could skyrocket into the hundreds of
thousands if not a million we cannot
return to normal until there's a vaccine
the earliest is
fifteen to eighteen months really
because that lunatic is advising the
quid-pro-quo well ever confused Joe
Biden campaign what he's suggesting yet
that would destroy the entire economy
ask yourself how many businesses could
survive with zero customers for eighteen
straight months it's not that hard to
figure out and Mister manual is far from
the only Democrat seemingly rooting for
what it would be a long-term economic
catastrophe of New York Governor the
ever incompetent all talk no action
Andrew Cuomo just promising New York
would not go back to normal anytime soon
well there's an ambitious plan so does
he think a months-long shut down for
America's biggest cities gonna be a good
thing does he not have any more creative
thinking than that because that would
forever alter the economy and the
country and why does nobody in the media
mob ever held hold that guy accountable
ever without a doubt all fifty states
have been impacted by Cova nineteen some
worse than others no state has had it as
bad as New York where we are tonight of
course New York City is the most densely
packed area of the United States we know
it's an international city that hosts
travelers from all over the world
smallest geographical area largest
amount of people it's obvious they are
more susceptible to pandemics Cuomo knew
this the Blasio knew this and yet they
both completely failed to prepare in any
way you can thank Donald Trump for
bailing you out in the new report the
former CDC chief found that if New York
had acted sooner with its stay-at-home
order the death toll could have been
reduced by a whopping 50 to 80 percent
in March
comrade de Blasio was telling New York
City residents to go out and enjoy the
theater Cuomo he was reassuring his
constituents that the risk was low on
March 2nd where do you hear what he said
I'm won't say well what were they saying
on Fox News yeah I was saying
asymptomatic people that are highly
contagious is dangerous I was saying
that in January and I was saying it
before anybody else but this is Cuomo
March 2nd
not that long ago a little over a month
take a look excuse our arrogance as New
Yorkers I speak for the mayor also on
this one we think we have the best
health care system on the planet right
here in New York and I know so when
you're saying what happened in other
countries versus what happened here
we don't even think it's going to be as
bad as it was another country I was a
little over a month ago right Andrew
well we have that arrogant that you
failed to prepare your state and your
city
don't forget Cuomo he was warned
directly in November of 2015 that New
York state would be fifteen thousand
seven hundred eighty-three ventilators
short during an influenza pandemic Cuomo
purchased none of what the task force
recommended and they said this is going
to happen we have a duty and a
responsibility to do this we have
another report by the way of another
warning from ProPublica which in 2006
they were also warned New York City's
pandemic plan called for the city to
purchase 9,500 new ventilators at the
time I got to give Mayor Bloomberg
credit he purchased five hundred and
guess what happened to those well they
didn't maintain them and then somewhere
between 20 14 and 16 nobody really knows
the ventilators were auctioned off to
some highest bidder we don't know who
has anyone in the media mob hold them
accountable for their failure any public
official in New York they ever going to
be held accountable because if Donald
Trump didn't build the biggest hospital
in the country if Donald Trump didn't
bill send his Navy hospital ship and
five other hospitals in New York and
send the masks and the reps paraders and
the ventilators they would have had
nothing oh and he's also staffing the
biggest Hospital in the country at the
Javits Center oh and they're taking
covert 19 patients because New York
wasn't prepared for anything
well the mob and the media they got a
pass every single time take a look what
are the risks and doesn't work those are
the questions that need to be answered
about hydroxychloroquine and
this debate continues to wage in the
White House with tensions growing
president Trump has asked what do you
have to lose medical experts say your
life Governor Cuomo saying Monday he's
seen some promising results in New York
where hospitals are allowed to use
hydroxychloroquine in conjunction with
the xethru myosin
I love Doc Cuomo was talking about cabin
fever trying to help people through the
the therapy part of this the psychology
of this experience and that's that's a
display of fantastic
crisis messaging this is an
administration that only acts in its own
self-interest which is just laid bare by
this crisis and daddy Governor Cuomo
shows what a leader does when he's
focused on that the safety of the people
I have to admit that I am a fan of
Andrew Cuomo and wish very much that he
were President of the United States now
wait'll America sees the way he spent
750 million on a failed solar panel
project and a six hundred million dollar
debacle on some computer chip and 90
million on some other of light bulb deal
in California all wasted all mothballed
you think any of these people would be
so forgiving a president Trump for not
buying 16,000 ventilators that he was
warned to buy never and even during a
worldwide pandemic they can't put aside
their hatred for Donald Trump for one
second and maybe that's why even now
some are rooting for the country to stay
in a constant state of lockdown which
means failure renowned economist Reagan
advisor art Laffer smart guy always
rooted for this country to succeed and
now he believes the key to get in the
country back on track is not another
massive new big government stimulus plan
instead laugher is advocating for the
payroll tax cut which would immediately
put real dollars in the hands of the
American taxpayers